[Musique]
et si Jean-Claude Van Damme avait vu
juste avant tout le monde
dans 23 ans il n'aura plus car après
avoir connu une pénurie d'essence il y a
quelques mois la France pourrait bien
prochainement manquer d'eau à en croire
certains spécialistes qui aujourd'hui
tirent la sonnette d'alarme la moitié de
la population mondiale subit déjà de
graves pénuries d'eau entre sécheresse
manque de pluie et faible débit dans nos
rivières l'inquiétude de voir cette
ressource naturelle essentielle
s'épuiser gagne même du terrain au
sommet de l’état il y a quelques jours
tandis que les tarifs de l'eau risque
d'augmenter Emmanuel Macron a présenté
son plan haut pour sensibiliser les
Français sur son utilisation le
changement climatique va nous priver de
30 à 40% de l'eau disponible dans notre
pays alors plusieurs spécialistes Sun
alertent allons-nous vers une pénurie
d'eau
merci d'être avec nous merci Badaoui
Rouban expert en adaptation au
changement climatique vous êtes ancien
directeur prévention catastrophe
naturelle à l'Unesco est-ce qu'on craint
réellement une pénurie d'eau tout à fait
tout à fait permettez-moi d'avoir de
dire que force est de constater ce soir
que le problème de l'eau a réussi en
l'espace de moins de deux semaines à la
fois d'être le sujet d'une conférence
internationale il y a deux semaines aux
Nations unies à New York et aussi d'être
un sujet dans l'émission Touche pas à
mon poste
se tenais à le dire c'est important plus
d'eau
il y aura une pénurie d'eau c'est pas
demain après demain ou dans les mots il
faut faire attention mais il faut
prendre conscience du fait que
l'abondance en eau c'est fini c'est fini
c'est fini quoi c'est fini c'est fini
de l'eau n'importe où n'importe comment
c'est fini
donc il va falloir tirer des
conséquences de ce constat il s'agit pas
d'être à l'armiste il s'agit pas
d'annoncer l'Apocalypse
d'eau c'est fini ça veut dire quoi c'est
à dire que je peux pas me faire 19 19
parce qu'on nous dit de boire beaucoup
d'eau il faut il faut il faut se calmer
là-dessus pour schématiser un peu en
l'année 2030 c'est-à-dire
il y aura il y aura
40% 40% de plus en besoin d'eau que ce
qu'il y a de disponibilité en eau c'est
à dire si nous sommes dans une commune
où il y a
1400 personnes qui ont besoin d'eau il y
aura 1000 qui pourront disposer de cette
eau et donc
4000 400 qui n'auront pas d'eau c'est
pour schématiser un peu en l'an 2030
donc il va falloir va falloir dès
maintenant il va falloir dès maintenant
prendre des mesures prendre conscience
de cela
et ce qui s'est passé avec le changement
climatique ne doit pas se passer avec
l'eau c'est à dire les experts dès
l'année 1990 les experts du monde nous
disaient le changement climatique est là
il va arriver il le disait des
on ne les a pas écoutés mais leur je
vous en prie juste parce que Monsieur on
nous dit depuis le début que avec le
réchauffement climatique la fonte des
glaciers Venise va être sous l'eau le
Mont Saint-Michel va être sous l'eau et
que l'autre prend de plus en plus de
place par rapport à la Terre par rapport
à la Terre donc de quel eau on parle ce
qu'on est en train de nous dire qu'au
contraire l'eau prenait de place sur la
main sur la terre parce que c'est
l'autre question très bonne question
en trois trois trous trip c'est à dire
nous nous dirigeons sur nous nous
dirigeons vers ou bien trop d'eau donc à
cause des précipitations pluviales donc
inondations
c'est-à-dire sécheresse et
manque d'eau ou bien trop sale
c'est-à-dire l'eau va polluer c'est pour
toi ça donc trop 3 trop 3 trop et donc
il faut que nous Lite que nous luttons
contre cette triptique néfaste donc en
fait funeste il y a pas de sens monsieur
comment il peut y avoir trop d'eau et
trop de sécheresse c'est le changement
climatique qui dicte les choses
la caractéristique du changement
climatique c'est les extrêmes
trop d'eau ou trop peu d'eau trop de
tempête ou pas du tout de devant
d'accord donc ce sont les extrêmes qui
caractérisent le changement climatique
on peut continuer à boire de l'eau
tranquille ou à chaque fois qu'on boit
de l'eau on a on doit se dire et
c'est bientôt pour un peu en boire comme
comme on veut mais il faut que nous
tirons des anciennement
l'eau nous la consommons depuis des
décennies n'importe comment n'importe
comment l'eau un individu consomme par
jour 5000 litres d'eau mais vous allez
me dire mais comment c'est pas possible
moi je prends une douche je consomme
seulement 10 litres d'eau ou 20 litres
d'eau mais 5000 litres d'eau par
personne ça provient de nos
consommations en vêtements
consommation en énergie à les centrales
nucléaires les vêtements les centrales à
tout à fait tout à fait
pour avoir du coton il faut de l'eau
bien sûr donc du coton nous consommons
par jour par individu 5000 litres d'eau
la planète dans 7 ans elle va nous dire
NON NON basta mais c'est sûr on peut pas
et donc il faut prendre des mesures si
c'est dans 7 ans c'est qu'on est déjà en
retard là c'est fini comment on pourrait
rattraper non non on n'est pas en retard
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire les bâtard
j'arrête le individuel qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire à titre individuel c'est très
important
l'homme et la femme sont les acteurs de
la lutte contre la pénurie d'eau tout
comme le changement climatique chacun et
chacune d'entre nous nous sommes
capables de lutter contre le changement
climatique il faut en prendre conscience
bien sûr ça ne dépend pas seulement des
services publics des gouvernements
chacun et chacune d'entre nous nous
avons notre destin en main dans notre
protection contre le l'effet du
changement climatique mais aussi contre
les pénuries donc comment faire cela
donc il faut être raisonnable de ne pas
laisser une fuite d'eau dans les
appartements il faut être raisonnable
quand on arrose la façon dont on arrose
il faut peut-être un jour un jour il
faut peut-être concevoir de réutiliser
les eaux usées mais pas demain après
faire sa personne va le faire donc il y
a il y a des dispositions que nous
pouvons envisager la science et la
technologie nous permettent de gagner
cette bataille tout comme la bataille
contre le changement climatique pour
faire ça tout le monde entier ça va être
compliqué
ça ne se produira pas en une décennie
mais les générations futures nous leur
devons cela
l'un de la Chine
là vous nous parlez nous mais nous on a
on est rien on est encore une fois
raison vous avez encore votre question
mais mais si chacun va dire la même
chose nous n'avons sur angle sur un
milliards on est 66 millions la Chine a
souffert il y a un an de pénurie d'eau
donc c'est pour ça que il y a eu dans le
monde entier une pénurie dans les chips
que nous utilisons pour les téléphones
portables et
donc ça c'était du pardon pour l'angle
d'utilisation il était survie cool donc
donc
ce soir
c'est un sujet très
critique l'eau et le parent l'eau et le
parent pauvre hélas des discussions sur
les changements climatiques je sais
c'est l'eau qui doit on dit d'ailleurs
on dit les experts disent depuis
quelques temps ils disent que le
changement climatique c'est un requin le
changement climatique c'est un requin
mais les dents de ce requin c'est l'eau
non
sur quoi est-ce qu'il y a toujours de
l'eau sur Mars
la filtration de l'eau de la mer alors
il a désallinisation c'est une solution
un scénario c'est ça et là c'est très
coûteux c'est très très coûteux combien
ces conneries
donc ça c'est mort
c'est à dire que là en ce moment juste
est-ce que on doit on doit faire
attention quand on se lave vraiment tout
le monde et tout le monde entier
absolument et la France est entrée dans
dans l'air de de de de restriction d'eau
c'est clair donc la France est entrée
dedans la date qui nous a dit en 2030
merci en tout cas franchement c'était
intéressant et non mais là ça nous a
fait flipper merci Badaoui Rouban et on
va faire attention grâce à vous je suis
sûr que tous les gens qui nous ont
regardé vont faire attention je sais
qu'on est très regardé en Chine et en
Inde parce que aussi vont essayer de
faire le maximum merci en tout cas